La volta al món a peu, dia 293.
Avui és divendres i mireu quin dia més rúfol.
Ahir vaig intentar gravar un vlog aquí a Tashkongar.
La volta al món a peu, dia 292.
Com veieu, el temps ha canviat bastant.
Bé, tu i a més estàs posant a plorar bastant.
Ves que no hagi de cancel·lar aquest vlog, perquè així no es pot visitar.
Però després d'això, va plorar tot el dia i vaig avortar missió.
Vaig tornar a l'hotel, vaig fer alguns tràmits en les postals,
però, males notícies, no les puc enviar des d'aquí perquè no tenen suficients segells.
Llavors, com que encara no m'ha arribat la visa de Pakistan,
i avui també he de fer un dia rúfol, avui també ha de ploure,
he decidit que me'n vaig a Kashgar.
Són les 9.30 ara mateix, horari Pekín, per tant és com si fos un 6.30,
i ara a mitja hora agafaré el bus que em portarà fins allà,
i allà és on esperaré.
A la visa d'Akistan, perquè Kashgar està bé, però és petit, té 40.000 habitants,
i Kashgar és més gran, és la capital de la regió, té 250.000 habitants.
Let's go!
A la visa d'Akistan, perquè Kashgar és més gran, té 250.000 habitants.
Kashgar, ja he arribat, després de 5 hores i mitja, m'esperava més, no està malament.
S'ha fet una mica pesat, però ja està.
M'he agafat un hòstel.
Sí, en comptes d'una habitació privada com faig sempre, he volgut estalviar una mica,
és molt barat, 3 dies, 22 euros, i a més podré socialitzar una mica.
El que passa és que l'autobús m'ha deixat a 3 quilòmetres del centre,
que és on està el hòstel, i bueno, trobo a caminar una mica.
Som-hi!
El hòstel està aquí a prop, estic flipant amb la ciutat aquesta.
Té 250.000 habitants, tipus Terrassa, Badalona o així,
però és que...
Els edificis són gegants, tot és gegant, hi ha moltíssima gent,
moltes motos d'aquestes, elèctriques, i molt bé decorat tot, guai, guai.
Hi ha la ciutat antiga aquí, que veurem després, però de camí al hòstel,
aquí hi ha una oficina de correus, una oficina de correus gegant, China Post.
Si aquí no tenen els segells, estic fotut, vaig a preguntar.
Doncs no, com he d'esperar, no en tenien tantes, però la Xiaolie,
que és una crac, l'empleada, ha fet servir un traductor que no calia ni apretar cap botó.
Anaven parlant i anava traduint automàticament. Boníssima, a més, crec que la traducció era boníssima.
Total, que m'ha dit que m'ho intentarà aconseguir pels propers dies, són moltes.
Pel dilluns m'ho intentarà tenir. Superbé, tant de bo, tant de bo.
Si no, les hauré d'enviar com un paquet a algú de Catalunya i que aquesta persona les enviï per correus nostres.
Espero que no hagui de fer això.
Vale, va, ara sí, anem al hòstel.
Primeres impressions del centre. Ostres, quina cosa més rara, no?
És una mesca entre això, entre Xina i algun lloc de Centràsia, d'Uzbekistan.
També una mica decorat, de pel·lícula.
Anem a dir que està restaurat i ja està.
I crec que aquí està el meu hòstel, tu.
Molt bé.
Moltes nits, espero no empenedir-me.
Espero no empenedir-me perquè és dormitori compartit amb altres 6 persones.
Doncs està bé el hòstel.
M'he agafat una habitació que són 6 llits.
I té una taquilla amb un codi secret per deixar les coses i que ningú t'ho robi.
Té la cortina allò per deixar.
Bueno, està bé. Després si no és una comuna, aniré aquesta nit.
D'acord, ara li he preguntat a la noia a la recepció a veure que em recomani un lloc per dinar
i m'ha dit un lloc de noodles.
Complicat demanar amb aquesta carta, que clar, no està en anglès.
He hagut d'anar traduint un per un.
I al final he demanat uns fideus amb carn de chai.
No m'esperava aquest tipus de fideus, m'esperava uns fideus més fins.
Està bo, però és una mica difícil d'agafar amb els pelillos.
Jo no tinc raça, però no tanta, o sigui, evidentment.
I arrellisquen bastant.
Mentre dinava he estat estudiant una mica la història de Caixgar.
Que us explicaré mentre camino per aquests carrers estrets del barri antic.
Doncs bé, això era un altre cop.
Ens trobem amb la Ruta de la Seda.
Sí, una de les paredes de la Ruta de la Seda, aquí a les faldes del Pamir.
Ara mateix ens trobem als mil i pico metres
sovint de bé del mar, no als 3.000, com estàvem a Traix Congar.
Vaig a manera curta, tan tranquil·lament.
Però sí, aquí hi havia punt de reunió entre turcs, perses, xinesos,
per intercanviar seda, bé, tot el que vaig explicar aquell dia a Samarkand, no?
I també hi havia uigurs, que són els habitants d'aquesta zona de sempre.
Els uigurs se'ls distingeix bé dels xinesos Han, perquè tenen la pell més fosca
i no tenen les faccions aquestes orientals, i són de religió musulmana.
Important. A veure, elements de la cultura uigur, no?
Doncs el barret, aquest que és com quadrat,
l'he vist a diverses dones que el porten, també a Traix Congar, encara que ja són teixics, però bueno.
El porten al mateix barret.
Els instruments.
Veig moltes parades de souvenirs que venen diferents tipus d'instruments de corda.
També una espècie de tambor.
També és bastant típic una espècie de ganivet, així com bastant ornamental.
La roba aquesta tan diferencial, que, bueno, aquesta és molt de...
Aquesta que veiem aquí deu ser molt de vestir.
Però sí que he vist persones que
porten robes així bastant tradicionals pel carrer, eh?
Ara mateix al barri antic, doncs, hi ha molt de turisme.
I és que no m'esperava això, eh?
No m'esperava que fos un lloc tan, tan, tan turístic.
Crec que d'aquí a poc són vacances a la Xina, i potser per això també.
Hi ha tanta gent.
Llavors aquí vivien els uigurs, no?
No va ser fins al 1750 i pico que la regió de Xinjiang, que és aquesta on estem ara,
va ser incorporada a la Xina per primera vegada.
Després també es van tornar a separar, va ser un estat independent,
i un altre que es van tornar a ajuntar fins ara.
El 2009, el govern xinès va dur a terme una reforma del centre de Qashgar,
reforma bastant intensa, que no va consistir en restaurar els edificis antics,
sinó en enderrocar-los.
Van decidir enderrocar-los i fer-los de nou.
Va haver-hi bastantes organitzacions de patrimoni mundial que van dir que no,
amb això no es pot fer, tal, i bueno, ho sé, ho van tirar i van tornar
a fer, suposo que estaven molt malestats o el que sigui.
Llavors, el que he dit abans de decorat de pel·lícula,
doncs sí, tenia raó, era bastant decorat de pel·lícula.
Jo he vingut del Pamir, de l'oest de Qashgar, però a l'est hi ha un desert,
el desert de Taklamant, crec que es diu.
És un dels deserts sorrencs més grans del món.
Desert sorrenc vol dir el típic desert que ens imaginem, que tot són dunes i sorra,
no és com el desert dels Montnegros, que arribes allà i dius, ostres,
m'imaginava una altra cosa, no, el típic desert, doncs aquest és un dels més grans del món.
Llavors, clar,
estaves a un lloc molt clau perquè totes les caravanes que havien de passar de la ruta
de la seda, mira, això sembla que s'ha marcat una mica,
doncs clar, aquí era el lloc clau per parar perquè després venia tot el desert,
que per cert, Taklamant o com es digui, en uigur vol dir, si entres, no surts.
Us sona aquest pa?
Bé, potser no us el vaig ensenyar, però és el pa típic d'Ozbekistan que vaig menjar
diverses vegades. Bé, al final totes aquestes cultures deuen
compartir coses i tenien moltes coses semblants.
Al final, depèn de quina definició busquis, això és central també.
Personatges famosos que van estar algun dia a Kashgar.
Doncs Jens Giscard, evidentment, va passar per aquí i va conquistar aquesta zona.
I Marco Polo.
A veure, molts cops m'heu dit alguns de vosaltres, ostres, Enric, ets Marco Polo, no sé què.
Bé, qui era Marco Polo?
No crec que ets senyor, no?
Any 1271.
Venècia. Regne de Venècia.
Marco Polo surt a explorar una mica, no?
I arriba fins a Turquia, després Iran, i allà vol agafar un vaixell fins a la Xina.
Però s'adona que els vaixells no eren segurs, no hi havia cap vaixell que el portés o el que sigui.
Llavors decideix fer el viatge per terra.
I aquesta és la part maca, que va anar per zones molt inhòspites, com tota la zona del Pamir,
fins a Kashgar.
I després de Kashgar ja va anar a Pekín.
24 anys després va tornar a Venècia i va escriure un cop va tornar,
doncs, memòries del seu viatge i tal, i per això és tan famós.
I bé, sí, fins ara més o menys, sense passar per l'Iran, però més o menys he fet una mica el trajecte de Marco Polo.
Estic intentant trobar la mesquita d'Izi, que és la mesquita més important de la ciutat.
I mentre vaig caminant per aquests carrers, ara sí que m'adono.
Això em sembla portaventura.
Portaventura en el sentit de que tot sembla cartó-pedra.
És maco, eh?
O sigui, com a decorat és maco.
Com a centre històric, sí, sí, sembla molt fake.
Mira, jo no m'he estat dos cops a la Xina aquesta vegada
i l'altra vegada vaig estar 9 hores a Pekín.
I, però bueno, per xarxes socials veus molt coses de la Xina i tal,
i sempre la gent parla, hi ha molts comentaris.
I es comenta molt aquest tema, no?, que hi ha moltes zones de la Xina que...
que estan molt turistificades i...
i no són prou autèntiques.
Bueno, no tinc prou esperança com per dir-ho, però aquí...
aquí m'ho sembla, i molt.
Pel que veig, molts dels cartells aquí estan només escrits en xinès, a la part antiga,
però restaurants i d'altres zones hi ha, bueno, molt escrit en uigur.
L'uigur és una llengua túrquica.
De fet, els uigurs estan emparentats, entre cometes, amb els de Kyrgyzstan, Kazakstan, turcs.
Però l'alfabet és... no és com el turc, que és l'alfabet llatí, sinó que deriva de l'àrab.
Clar, jo, l'àrab, no sé res.
Jo veig aquestes lletres i a mi tot em sembla el mateix, àrab.
Però es veu que no, es veu que...
canvia, canvia de l'àrab.
Molt... l'alfabet àrab que...
que fan servir els uigurs és molt diferent de l'alfabet àrab que fan servir els marroquins, per dir alguna cosa.
Ni idea, tu.
Això, per barris, hi ha els barris de les guitarres, hi ha els barris de... dels ganivets, i aquest és el barri de...
d'estir, jugar-lo i pagar perquè et facin una foto.
Ostres, tu, que maco ets, espera.
Ah, tot.
És clar, que ja està.
Mireu-vos-hi, eh, això.
Això, aquesta és la Ridge.
Ha sigut una gran estirada, eh?
Deu ser, ha sigut.
Però, per què?
El barri és molt llarg i l'aeroport, el barri és molt llunyà.
És d'aquesta manera, ha sigut.
Hi ha el barri, aquí.
Però, on és el barri?
Sí, és l'aeroport del barri.
Sí, és un barri.
Doncs aquí hi ha la mesquita, que no sé quin nom he dit abans,
però es diu Yitka.
De color groc, també bastant restaurada pel que sembla,
amb la bandera xinesa a dalt de tot, que no falti.
A veure si em deixen entrar.
Doncs no.
Està tancada.
Està tancada aquesta hora, ja està.
Ja no és hora de visita, deu ser hora de...
de resar.
Mira tu, com la plaça Catalunya,
però concentrats només en una botiga, saps?
No molesten a tota la ciutat i es van cagant pertot arreu.
No sé si són coloms, però s'assemblen.
Són blancs. Aquí ma mare no podria vindre, li fan pols ocells.
Les 8 de la tarda ja ha arribat el final de la ciutat antiga,
que és molt gran.
I no he explorat ni el 30%.
Aquesta és la part de la ciutat, com jo dic, que va per barris,
on hi ha música en directe, hi ha una noia cantant.
Canta molt bé.
I aquí veiem, doncs, l'altra part de la ciutat,
amb aquesta torre de comunicacions aquí,
i la Nora a l'altra banda.
M'agrada.
M'agrada...
Xina, en general.
Aquest lloc, aquesta ciutat.
Si fos tota la volta amb una peu així, no.
No, per què no?
Però, especialment venint de Teixiquistà,
el contrast és brutal.
Estem a pocs quilòmetres de distància, però el contrast és...
és increïble.
Vaig al hostel,
que m'han dit que per la nit a la terrassa es lia bastant.
Bona nit, estem a la terrassa
de l'hotel i tenim aquí
el Terrence.
Està molt bé.
100% o...?
Jo diria 100%.
Com més confortable és l'hospital,
més bé.
Quan m'havies dit que havies estat 6 hores allà
i et van donar medicaments,
i tot,
estic sorprès.
I tu t'has pagat quant?
Més o menys 14 dollars.
Per tot el dia vaig veure dos especialistes.
Vaig tenir tots els drogues per curar tot el vell.
Tot bé.
Em van complir molt sobre el pass de Colma,
que em va demanar una hora de relaxació.
Quanta estona vas tenir allà?
4 o 5 hores.
Jo i l'André hi vam estar 4 o 5 hores.
Ens van cercar, crec,
dues vegades, oi?
Nosaltres vam anar a buscar-nos dues vegades.
Ens van interrogar o ens van preguntar
moltes preguntes.
Ens van treure la informació de tots els nostres passaports,
perquè tots tenim dos passaports.
Aquesta va ser la qüestió,
que tu tinguessis dos passaports i ells eren especialistes?
No ho sé.
Hi va haver moltes coses.
El passaport,
el control de l'estat d'estat era lliure,
però va durar molt de temps.
Vam passar tot el dia allà.
On aneu a la propera?
Potser a Urumqi.
I després,
aniré a la vietnama
i a Singapur amb bicicleta.
Tens una visa?
No encara.
Has d'anar a la Xina?
Per la Xina tinc una visa de 2 mesos.
Però per la Vietnama...
La Xina és tan gran
que puc aplicar-la
l'any que ve.
Anem a
l'home més feliç de la taula,
que és
Harry.
L'home més feliç de la taula.
Harry, érem aquí,
menjant birra,
i ell...
Estava pensant
sobre què volia preguntar a tothom.
La meva qüestió era
que estigués aquí,
com jo, esperant la visa de Pakistà,
però ho has rebut ara mateix.
Literalment, 5 minuts abans,
m'he trobat amb joia,
perquè anava
a Urumqi el diumenge,
tenint la Vietnama
a Xinjiang per un mes i mig,
i un mes d'això
estava esperant la visa de Pakistà.
Un mes i mig.
Bé, felicitacions. Estic feliç.
L'envia em correu.
Has estat aquí un mes i mig.
Què m'ha recomanat?
La activitat número 1 que hauria de fer.
El mercat animal,
si no has vingut a molts mercats de la vida,
és increïble, és massiu.
Sant Jordi, no?
Sant Jordi.
És a 10 km d'aquí.
La massiva estatua del president Mao,
a 20 metres de tall.
És molt cool de veure,
perquè és tan visceral.
És un mausoleum
per a alguns calmes.
Crec que és
Youssef Haj? No m'explicis això.
D'un camí de 20 minuts
a l'estat.
És molt usbèc,
en el sentit de les tiles
vermelles.
És molt cool.
A part d'això,
viatjar al voltant de l'antiga ciutat,
socar-la,
i menjar-la.
Socar-la, menjar-la,
menjar-la,
menjar-la.
La gent de la ciutat
que ve al voltant
ve de la ciutat,
de la ciutat de l'estat,
i me'n vaig a casa demà, però m'hauria d'acabar la visita al gener o febrer,
tant a Laos com a Vietnà.
Bé, bona sort, tindré el teu número i em diràs com està el Paquistan i tot.
100%.
Ara anem a l'André, andré brasileiro, brasileiro de onde?
Brasileiro de São Paulo.
Paulista.
Nunca estive en São Paulo, estive en Rio, Bahia e Belém, Belém do Pará.
E qual é o seu modo de transporte?
Travelling by bicycle.
No, pots parlar en portuguès.
Ah mira, doncs bé.
Jo viatjo de bicicleta.
Bicicleta.
On va començar la teva viatge?
Va començar a Xi'an.
Xi'an és la Xina, no?
Sí.
A l'est de la Xina.
Set mesos abans.
Uau.
Llavors tu...
Tu coneixes tot, la Xina, no?
Set mesos?
En realitat, de Xi'an, vaig anar a Pekín i vaig arribar a Mongòlia.
Ah.
Travessé a Mongòlia.
Com és Mongòlia?
Ah, incrível.
Jo vaig prendre una època de vent contra molt forta.
Ells es diuen allà el vent que travessa les costelles.
És el nom del vent d'abril.
I quan, quin mes va ser això?
Març i abril.
Un poc fred, fred, no?
Estava fred.
Ok.
De tu, de tot el seu viatge,
quina és la part que més t'ha agradat?
Quina és la part que més t'ha agradat?
Uau, que pregunta difícil.
Jo no sé dir...
Has d'escollir una.
Sóc una.
Una regió.
O país.
Pots ser, no sé...
Muntanyes.
Jo diria la cordillera Tian Shan.
No sé què és.
Vam ficar no vídeo o mapa de dover iso,
porque no conozco.
Ok, é o peor momento, o a peor região?
A Mongòlia foi muito difícil.
Melhor comida...
Xina.
Mas una en especial, que você gostou tanto.
Qualquer noodles.
E a pior?
A pior comida.
Mongòlia tamé.
Cara, en Mongòlia em van donar estómago de boig,
pulmón de boig,
amb pescó de... no sé què.
A Mongòlia va ser el pitjor.
Ok, i ara, quina és la pròxima destinació?
Paquistà.
Paquistà també, eh? Estàs esperant la visa o ja en tens?
Ja en tinc. Estic només relaxant.
La envidia em correu.
Ok, ok. Bé, molta sort.
Gràcies.
Ok.
Adéu.
Bé, ja veieu que les llengües són molt importants per viatjar,
tant per contactar amb viatgers com per demanar ajuda.
Per això m'alegro molt de presentar-vos Langkora.
Vols aprendre un idioma?
Ja sigui per viatjar, per parlar amb amics que visquin altres països,
per treballar... Vols aprendre'l de veritat?
Més enllà de certificats, exàmens, aprendre's la gramàtica de memòria?
Doncs compte amb l'acadèmia Langkora.
És una acadèmia online on podreu aprendre qualsevol idioma
i al ser online us oferiran màxima flexibilitat
per adaptar-se als vostres horaris.
Que ja saps un idioma però el tens una mica rovejat i tal,
doncs també ofereixen classes només de conversa per a adults.
Atenció perquè Langkora també està especialitzada en formacions
per a empreses de diferents sectors.
Si voleu aprendre un idioma, esteu interessats?
Aneu a la seva web, langkora.com, doneu-li una ullada
i també teniu l'enllaç a la descripció o contacteu-los per mail o com vulgueu.